but we're gonna begin with this a new
lawsuit filed overnight blames gun
manufacturers and dealers for the
deadliest mass shooting in modern US
history in October 2017 a gunman opened
fire on an outdoor concert in Las Vegas
58 people were killed and nearly 500
others were wounded among those killed
31 year-old Carrie Parsons now only on
CBS this morning
her parents explain why they're suing
the makers of the military-style rifles
used in the attack and the dealers who
sold them she was on top of the world
who just gotten engaged so excited her
business career was going great I mean
she was so so excited in the fall of
2017 life was good for Carrie Parsons
and she flew to Las Vegas to celebrate I
had been given my assignments my
mother-of-the-bride assignments that I
was supposed to start looking at bad
news
but while Carrie's excited parents Jim
and anne-marie planned for a wedding
back home there you go a gunman opened
fire on their daughter and thousands of
others at a Country Music Festival when
did you get the final word that she had
not just been shot but have been killed
so that first day when I got there they
had us in a room and then finally I saw
them coming down the hall and it was an
army of doctors and then at the very
back was a person and a clerical collar
and they didn't even have to tell me how
is it possible for a shooter 32 stories
up and hundreds of yards away to hit
your daughter fatally it's the power of
these weapons these are weapons of war
so you don't have to be a marksman to
shoot 300 or 600 yards he didn't target
anyone he just mowed them down they
didn't have a chance as the Parsons
later learned the shooter had used a
dozen different rifles each one modified
to simulate a machine gun with automatic
fire and allowing him to shoot more than
a bullet a second but machine guns have
been banned since 1986 in a lawsuit the
couple filed last night claims a gun
that's easily modifiable to fire
automatic
is a machine-gun therefore flatly
illegal under federal and state law the
suit names 16 defendants the makers and
sellers of guns used in the Las Vegas
massacre we contacted the defendants and
the companies either declined to comment
or did not respond well the problem is
you're selling a machine gun by law
Josh koskoff is the couple's lawyer well
you've heard the phrase I'm sure guns
don't kill people people kill people
that sounds pretty catchy my answer is
people kill people with guns the amount
of firepower that rained down on those
concert goers on October 1st could not
have occurred without an ar-15 modified
by a bone stock to boot because it just
dumped out so much lead for such a
prolonged period of time that kind of
firepower is what killed carry no one
has ever won a lawsuit of this kind
against the gun manufacturer in part
because a 2005 law protects the
manufacturers against lawsuits when
their product is used for criminal
purposes but for the Parsons this is
about their daughter justice for her and
hitting the gun industry where it hurts
what do you think motivates these gun
manufacturers profit money money money
profits they live in this country too
though they have children they go to
church they go to sports games how are
they going to reconcile when they're 85
years old and on their death beds all
the devastation that they have helped
happen to families that's Emery Parsons
there the parson say and this is
interesting they don't blame the shooter
in their daughter's death because to
them there will always be unstable
people it's the military style weapons
that make mass shooters so deadly they
also say they do support gun ownership
in this country just not the ownership
of ar-15 style rifles honey you were
saying this is the same lawyer who took
a case to the Connecticut Supreme Court
which they actually won correct which
means the case can go forward the gun
manufacturers have very broad immunity
from lawsuits but there are these narrow
exceptions this lawyer has already found
one and he believes with this research
looking at the statutes around machine
guns he may have found another but you
hear from the Parsons family
particularly the mother where she paints
a scene of people coming to give her the
news that she knows is coming that you
don't want to hear and the fact that
they make that you
can fire and get hit from so far away I
didn't realize that and was hit in the
shoulder only in the one bullet to the
shoulder she was hundreds of yards away
she actually made it to an ambulance
they still couldn't save her that's how
deadly these weapons are and the gunman
you know he modified the weapon so he
was able to even with reloading and even
with switching guns shoot more than a
thousand rounds in less than ten minutes
yeah I mean I was at that scene it's you
you don't think it's possible but it was
sort of there were so many people on
that field for that concert that night
it was almost if you elbow what you have
to do with it and you want to talk about
families a few years ago and I'll never
forget this I spoke to the children of
the man who invented the ar-15 rifle
intended it for military purposes they
said their father would be sickened and
horrified by the fact it's in civilian
hands yeah
they raised some very interesting
questions thank you Tony